well halt there i enjoyed yourself here
at Budds be playing would you rather I
get real intense with these games
because my imagination goes wild and I
feel like what I answer is what I have
to do I take this game very seriously
would you rather be forced to wear a wet
socks for the rest of your life or be
allowed to wash your hair only once a
year
fun fact I actually don't wash my hair
at all I choose the second one woohoo
dry feet for me would you rather have a
finger as a tongue or have tongues as
fingers definitely have tongues for
finger oh wait actually no that would be
kind of gross because then you'd like
would you taste or would it just feel
imagined having a damn finger as a
tongue oh my god no okay I choose the
damn tongue as fingers where someone
else's dirty underwear or use someone
else's toothbrush I can't even use my
own boyfriend's toothbrush using someone
else's toothbrush is so disgusting to me
so wearing someone else's dirty
underwear
sure whatever Oh poop bricks or puke
slugs
I feel like pooping bricks would be it
actually extremely painful I'm gonna say
no to that and I will puke some slugs in
Harry Potter and I feel like if Ron
could do it I could do it pee yourself
in public once a week or poop your pants
in private daily I feel like peeing
yourself in public would be okay if you
had a diaper on
but pooping our pants privately oh I
would go with pooping my pants privately
yeah that's fine
would you rather always have to tell the
truth or always lie honesty is the best
policy so I'd rather tell the truth
would you rather have your body found in
a pile of sex toys
apparently I've already died so what's
it matter or have everyone you know see
your browsing history I think seeing my
browsing history is fine I have nothing
to hide never be allowed to wash your
hands after using the bathroom again or
only be allowed one square of toilet
paper every single time use the bathroom
for the rest of your life are you
freaking kidding me
that's impossible but you know what
there are things called bidets that you
could use so ha I found a loophole would
you rather not be allowed to brush your
teeth for a month or not be allowed to
shower for a month oh my god well I'd
rather not be allowed to brush your
teeth for a month because you could use
mouthwash so
would you rather not shave wax or cut
etc any hair for a year or not wear
deodorant for you oh well the only thing
I really shave is my face looks so weird
I had like a really massive ear and put
deodorant I can't think of like a way to
get around that ah the pressure um I
guess I would do the not wearing
different for a year
looks like my life is going to be
terrible because now I made some pretty
awful choices but I did find some good
loopholes around the choices that I have
so I'm about to go live my life with all
the choices I just made thanks for
watching bye